what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday the 25th of august a
beautiful [__] day to be alive the
joint is brought to you by and i'm
welcome back to the show
me undies the best in the [__]
business
i still have 200 pairs of me undies even
though they weren't with us for the last
year
i still been wearing their underwear why
because they're the [__] goods that's
why i love me undies me undies are
designed to be the softest thing on
earth that may sound like i'm [__]
exaggerating but it's the truth softer
than a baby's butt
softer than a feather softer than a
carvel cake that's been sitting in the
sun
meundies signature micro modal fabric
literally grows from trees that means
those undies are soft and sustainable i
have all of them from over the years no
holes no nothing
they're all different cuts because
they're cool
they get you different cuts for
different butts that's their motto plus
check out their socks bralettes
loungewear and of course the undies all
ranging from extra small to 4xl for you
chubby [__]
meundies has a great offer for the
church i mean for the joint listeners
for any first timers get 15 percent off
your first order and free shipping at
meundies.com
joey i love these underwear i [__]
wear them every goddamn day
i got every pattern every design i still
got some in packages i'm gonna have me
and they're gonna bury me in [__] me
undies that's how much i love them
they're comfortable they keep your nuts
[__] smelling tremendous they keep
the sweat away why
because of modal micro modal is fabric
that grows on trees and it's just
[__] comfortable so do me a favor go
to me undies problem free philosophy if
you're not satisfied with any product
for any reason
don't refund or exchange it
no questions asked that's me undies dot
com
slash joey plus they're going to give
you free shipping and 15 off your first
order
at meundies.com
joey comfort where it counts the joint
is also brought to you by
zip recruiter
listen things are reopening the movies
restaurants
people looking for employees you want a
job every place is hiring night right
now
ford's magazine says jim's hotel salons
are set to go on an epic hiring spree in
the first couple of months millions of
jobs will be need to be filled as
businesses keep reopening how do you
hire people fast
you know what i'm trying to say to you
zip recruiter try it for free at
ziprecruit.com
joey you got nothing to lose
here's the difference with zip recruiter
you're not posting a job
and waiting for resumes from joe schmoe
to come in zip recruiter has a fancy
technology that finds the best people
for the job and it helps you get them
right now you could try ziprecruiter for
free
joey what are you talking about i have a
small business listen for free
medium business for free this is going
to help you you understand me
ziprecruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com
joey that's ziprecruiter.com
joey j-o-e-y
try it for free it's the smartest
way
to hire the joint is also brought to you
by
my personal favorite cbd lion
from the cbd gummies with melatonin that
you sleep like a [__] bear
to the back balls to the cream you
cannot go wrong with cbd lion go to
cbdline.com read that third party lab
results and you'll see what i'm talking
about it is the most helpful
web page out there i love it because of
their web page and the help they give
you
customer service 101 at
cbdline.com and the product is
tremendous but it starts with you go to
cbdlion.com right now
press in joey or joint
and get 20 off and you get cbd products
delivered right to your crib who's
better than you go with cbd lion if you
want to take care of yourself your mind
and your body let's get this podcast
started
we got tim dillon on here today we ain't
got time to play games people let's do
this
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you beautiful
[__] it's wednesday
the 25th of [__] august
that's it we're getting close to the
[__] labor day
the summer's coming to a [__] end
and we're making it happen
i'm still away but we had time to do the
[__] podcast for you and we got a
great guest this week uh
it's [__] weird man comedy
you never know anything about comedy
you know when you get into comedy you
get in there
with this blind you know you don't want
to you don't know where you want to go
you don't want to raise your head and
say i'm a comic
and i want to be a movie star i'm a
comic and i want to have a [__] tv
show
you're getting ahead of yourself you
never know where you're going to end up
so when you become a comic
like i did i just became a comic to
become a comic i didn't become a comic
to be on tv i didn't become a comic to
be on hbo i just wanted a life
and i didn't want to be a [__]
criminal anymore that's the only reason
why i got into comedy it was the last
resort
for a guy like me sometimes
you know
i had no [__] ged i had a ged i
didn't have anything going on
then i got the felony and i knew i
couldn't keep beating the [__] same
old drum so
comedy was something i could [__]
tolerate if you saw me on stage
in 94 could you tell
that i was to be something no
no not at all
you know i couldn't [__] tell i i i
was lucky
if i would just be able to stay in
comedy for 10 years never mind 30
[__] years
by the time i was doing comedy five
years
i had an identity
you know you you have an identity it's
like
it's like when you hear three chords on
a [__] guitar
you know you know if it's
david gilmore you know if it's jimmy
page you know if it's [__]
you know you know if it's the guy from
[__] motley crue i mean
you know from their courts they don't
have to tell you eric clapton
you know and that's what happens with
stand-up you start seeing people
and you go wow that person's getting
better you know you never think that
that person is going to be a star
you could just that's why i love
watching comedy i always loved watching
comedy
and watching my friends do comedy
because you could tell like holy [__]
they're going somewhere with this
you really don't know
you know
i never judge what the industry said it
was always me watching you on stage
going this [__] could rock this
chick's a bad [__] here but i
can never really
tell then you start getting what's
called
industry heat
which is you know you start going to
montreal and the moon tower and the
festivals or whatnot
and you still can't really tell because
listen if you saw me
in
you would say joey diaz didn't have a
[__] chance
the same way rogan said it rogan always
said that when he met me
i was struggling so if you saw me
the first seven years in comedy
you would have said this poor bastard
doesn't have a chance in fact one of the
things
that till this day bothers me and it was
my ex-girlfriend
her brother we went to a show one night
her brother came
and her brother looked at a comic that i
was there and i think he said it to get
under my [__] skin
or he said it uh just because he was a
[__] [__]
he goes that comic right there is gonna
go places
and i made a mental note i was like i'm
gonna make a mental note if this guy
knew what the [__] he was talking about
i mean it was 1995.
i was only doing comedy four years i
didn't really have any expectations then
but for this idiot to say that this guy
was going to be a [__] star in 20
years
so i remember
it it lit a [__] light under my ass
you know like i'm like i got to be funny
in this guy
and it also made me stay in touch with
this guy like i would stay in touch with
him over the years
and the result was this
i got somewhere
and this guy's still in this little
[__] hell hole
doing 50 [__] gigs
you know the potential
was there but he didn't look at how i
did i on the other hand
started off slow
and picked up momentum
you know like i said in 1998
i was already irregular at the store
but i was a regular because of my
presence
not because it was going out of my mouth
it was my presence and my energy
that's what
pulled me along
those [__] days and i'm really proud
of that you know what
like i've said it to you guys before i'm
no john mulaney i'm no bill burr i'm
joey [__] coco diaz i'm a
storyteller
i do observational comedy you know i
improvise whatever the [__] i do i wish
i could write like those guys but that's
not the way it worked out
everybody has a different journey on
this [__]
earth you know and with comedy you never
[__] know you just
go
do you think i can be on tv i don't
[__] know i'm not gonna sit here and
blow smoke up your ass until you're
gonna be on tv you know but
you're not gonna be on tv
if you don't [__] go for it that's a
start right there i don't know you know
the other night we were watching the
world series of [__] softball my
father-in-law called and he's like
it's eight it's nine to twelve-year-olds
see if mercy wants to watch it you know
and i called mercy she had come out of
the shower and we're watching this
[__] world series the [__] girl
was thrown 95 miles an hour
she was 12 years old or some [__] you
know so
you know i could just watch girls
softball for 10 15 minutes and then i
start feeling like a [__] pedophile
but thank god i'm there with my daughter
and my wife
so i don't feel even [__] worse than
what i do feel i'm sitting there i got
my sweats on i'm relaxing and i'm
watching this [__]
and i told mercy mercy it's gonna be
nine o'clock
in a little while you're gonna have to
hit the [__] crib and she goes okay
dad
and finally she went over kissed her mom
and she came over to me and she gave me
a kiss and as she was walking to her
bedroom she turned around she looked at
me she goes you know what
one day i'm gonna play softball on
[__] tv
and i was like holy [__] my [__]
jaw dropped
and i'm like this is [__] tremendous
that
for her it was kind of the same thing
for me
like i was
playing basketball i got left back i was
lost and
i was learnt trying to learn moves and
[__] you know
different things from watching college
basketball and pro basketball i would be
addicted to it
and one day i'm watching a college game
on a [__] saturday afternoon
and they say something about jersey city
you know and
i was like what the [__] there's
somebody on this team from jersey city
and i remember i went to the courts that
sunday and i asked somebody i was
watching the ncaas and they said there
was a kid down there from jersey city
and my wife from there yeah there's a
kid on [__] north carolina from
jersey city he goes i forget what his
name is so i was like [__] it that
monday was the final game of the ncaa
final was the end of march madness and
i'll never forget i sat by the tv
waiting for the game to come on and it
was marquette versus north carolina
[__] liner in the finals phil ford
all these [__] players jerome
whitehead
but when they brought up north carolina
they said starting forward
a freshman from jersey city new jersey
six foot seven inches
michael corrin a [__] irish kid with
bad skin and acne and i remember when i
[__] you know cause when you hear
jersey city
it's one thing
but to see this [__] beautiful white
boy come out with his baby blue [__]
shirt and he was number 31 and also on
the bottom
because remember hearing and seeing is
two different [__] things
when i saw jersey [__] city my head
blew up it was like my daughter tasting
black beans for the first time you could
see something wasn't right she was like
eight months old and she was like
she was stuttering like lebron
so [__] when i saw that i [__]
went nuts i was like holy [__] that was
my life's inspiration
if i got to tell you what my life's
biggest inspiration was was seeing
michael coren that day and jersey city
because jersey city
turns into north bergen and if a jersey
city kid could be on [__] tv
so can a [__] north bergen kid and
that's how i looked at it i had to look
at it that way
that inspired me for the rest of my life
the other day i was sitting there and
i'm like i'm thinking of calling my man
jim hague he writes for the
the one of the jersey newspapers in
jersey city he gave me o'corin's number
about a year ago before the pandemic and
he told me to call i i told him i go
coren inspired me in ways that i could
never be [__] inspired before
and he goes here's his number give him a
call now i'm [__] embarrassed
but i was embarrassed the time but after
thinking about what he did for me and
[__] i said [__] it
it's time to call michael corrin so
maybe we'll have him on the [__]
podcast and we'll talk about how he
inspired me and whatnot he coached the
nets he's an announcer now he's great
but that was for my daughter to say that
to me the other day
i felt like how i felt in the [__]
seventh grade
when i saw michael coran i knew i was
going to do something with my life as
crazy as it sounds and look at years
later anyway i'm going i'm heading up to
shoot a tv show so
50 [__] years later
it panned out for me anyway
this week's guest is uh
you know i'm getting older
i love looking i want when i was doing
comedy i loved
going to the store earlier and watching
different comics do their [__] thing
you know
but i really enjoyed i didn't enjoy the
names i enjoyed
the door guys
you know
uh
there was one guy that used to do
saturdays early
i forget what isn't it
offalo or something in la i forget what
his name is he used to [__] kill me
on saturday nights i would go down there
early just
benny ruffalo whatever is that his name
benny i think i don't know
he was just funny as [__] at the store
there were some guys at the store that
made me [__] laugh my ass off that
you wouldn't know if you know just all
guys and young guys that were just
really funny
you know this this guy that i had on the
podcast this week i feel that
him
schultz you know these guys all have
the ticket on [__] comedy it's just a
matter of time
before they become stars am i jealous
[__] no
i'm happier for these guys i'm happy for
people when they strive
because i want people to strive my job
is to pull people up
about 15 years ago i met with this dude
i was talking to him
at lunch this was before i got back into
stand stand-up and the church
and he goes you really gotta work stand
up and be a mentor
for younger guys you know give them
light because the more light you give
them the more that you'll get he was
right this is what rogan has done over
the years
with his podcast you got to give younger
comics
light you can't be jealous of them or
judge them or say they're going to suck
[__] no
you got to say you know [__] salute
and [__] wishing the best
and this guy i called last week we
talked i i heard something about him i
checked in on him
and i asked him if he wanted to do the
podcast and we had a great time so
here he is
mr tim dillon enjoy i'll be back at the
end of this to check in with you
[__]
tim dillon looking good
what's up brother how are you how are
you my brother
thanks for having me how are they
treating you down in austin
i'm about out of here you know i mean
i'm about i'm little by little about to
uh
i'm going back to los angeles we just
got i got an apartment
the other day and then i have a house
here that i own but
i'm i'm gonna
i'm fixing it up and i'm going to try to
maybe rent it out
uh and hold on to it for a little bit
absolutely look at it as an investment
where you going right
you're on the road you're doing your
stuff
i'm on the road just recovering from
covin i got it i don't know where i got
it i think those bastards in orange
county gave it to me
and um you know i'm still a little beat
i'm a little tired
but i've beat most of it but i'm a
little fatigued
what is it like four or five days now
i got diagnosed i got i tested positive
last
[Music]
tuesday last wednesday last wednesday
and now it's um
so wednesday thursday friday
saturday sunday
monday where what is it uh
eight days it's eight days so far you
know it's a [__]
it's a little bit of a [__] it lingers
it lingers you know it's a it lingers
it's one of those things where even
after you beat it there's levels to
beating it
no [__]
yeah you gotta take vitamins and stuff
gotta take all that [__] you gotta just
you gotta you gotta rest up and build
you know i'm walking like three miles a
day now two and a half three miles a day
and you're trying to get your energy up
things like that but i i was lucky
people got it a lot worse to me
a lot of people have gotten a lot worse
than you and that's what i don't
understand like i know jiu jitsu schools
i know a bunch of people that have not
gotten it
yeah and they're wrestling with
[__] every day and getting bit
on the neck and then you know nobody has
a [__]
you know now it that's one of those the
variation in our species is one of the
reasons that one virus could never take
us all down it's very interesting a
doctor explained that to me because the
fact that certain people aren't getting
it means that there will be no one virus
that'll get everybody
so that's interesting it's like he goes
a virus can never take out humanity
because some [__] just won't
get it
well knock on wood i haven't gotten it
yet but
i'm not you know
you never [__] know you you don't
know what you know i swam in the hudson
i went on triple runs and ate that
foreign ass on triple runs that montana
ass and [__]
if that doesn't build your [__]
immune system nothing will you
understand me so you've got a very
strong immune system well no knock on
wood we're still not out of the [__]
woods yet you know but you think about
you know you've been on planes for 20 or
at least for me
i've been traveling for 20 years god
knows what's on those [__] planes
yeah you know and i would always get
prepared before i get on a plane
now i don't want to get on a [__]
plane it's just like i'm not in the
[__] mood right now after 20 [__]
years i hear you i get it i don't want
to get on a plane either
but i'll have to but yeah no
i think that uh
hopefully we're on the way out of this
we're gonna have it's gonna be a little
nasty in the fall and then hopefully by
the time we get to christmas
new year's
it's looking better it's looking real
good and by the time we get to next
spring we're golden
you think we will be able to sing in our
homes this christmas
band singing last year on christmas hey
ben remember that they banned singing
yeah they're not i don't think they're
gonna ban anything i don't think they're
gonna shut anything down
i think it's just you know we're gonna
have to learn to live with it this
thing's not going anywhere
you know in a way you should be happy
you got it over with yeah you're gonna
live and now you can't get it unless
it's a different [__] variant right
and it will be but
it will be
god only knows what varian's coming next
i'm happy i'm alive dude
when i know people
uh
you know i don't know anyone directly
but i do know people that are
you know that i know that they're real
who uh died of this who've died and
who've you know have not
uh made it out so it's it's it's good to
just say hey i'm i lived
now you could really go for it you know
the reason why
i thought about you for the podcast was
because somebody was asking me the other
day they're like you know with comedy
how do you feel about other comics and
i'm like well
i gotta be honest with you
the comics that i met at the store like
let's just take the store for example
i cheer for you guys
like i'm i'm an old [__] fart you
know what i'm saying i got maybe
five [__] years left you know
i enjoy being a dad i enjoy being home
but i look at you guys and you guys got
the world by the balls now
and i'm sitting here on the sidelines
cheering for you [__] savages like i
told you when you first talked to me
about you know leaving austin i said to
you bro
go back to la the team is ready for you
that's it you're the you're the next one
on the totem pole
you know if you want it if you want it
you're the next one i appreciate it you
we think you're a young man you just
need to
to realize how young you are you're
young at heart and and everywhere else
um i yeah i had to get out of austin
austin
uh you know
i never fell in love with it the way
that joe did or the way that other
people did it just wasn't
it it didn't grab me it didn't catch me
i it wasn't for me i mean
i don't know what people are seeing that
fall in love with it but
they're seeing something and then maybe
it's that i'm not seeing it
uh but they're
i i just you know i gave it a shot
for months months and months and months
and uh
you know it's one of the least favorite
places i've ever lived and i've lived on
the east coast i lived on the west coast
uh but living here has been an education
because now i say to myself
this is not for me
well at least you got out of the way
listen when it came to me
when rogan proposed austin to me i was
very happy at first
i have nothing against austin i love i
love going there once a year right we
all do we all love it for a few hours i
love that double tree
yeah and i love that [__] uh papados
you just roll out of bed and walk across
the street
i thought that was one of the easiest
weeks in the country for me and i
enjoyed the people
and i saw what they were trying to do
and i was at first i told juggle let me
just think about it
but i had my heart set on new jersey
i've been here a year today
yeah a [__] year
so it's like
i just wanted to come to jersey because
i was
i wanted to be around my family
well that's it and you know everybody i
think somebody told me once they said if
you're lucky enough you get to go home
this is what somebody told me once which
i think made a lot of sense i'm like i
think about that sometimes after you
know i do my thing in l.a and you know
will i end up back on the east coast i
don't know but somebody said to me once
he said if you're lucky enough you get
to go back home and i think you were
lucky enough you worked your ass off you
worked really hard you made a lot of
good things happen
and and then you had the benefit of
being able to go back to the place that
you grew up that made you who you were
and you have your daughter now and your
wife and you could show them
the experiences you know that you had
growing up there
well she's thanked me
about a week two weeks ago my daughter
took me aside eight years old and she's
like dad thank you
for bringing me here thank you for
turning me on to your food she [__]
loves white castle
you know she'll ask me twice a week can
we go to white castle you know yeah she
loves [__] carvel i mean i took her
out
yes she loves carvel she's all over
[__] carvel la uh well yeah last
night she asked me because i took it to
a football game she's like you know it's
uh get a sunday free today carpel
i'm like we're not [__] going to
carve out because i i take her once a
week for her every now and then her a
little [__] uh vanilla ice cream soda
yeah but even like i could tell how she
treats
the people i grew up with
right contrast to other people she
really digs them
she really goes out of their way to talk
to him she's at she asked some questions
like did you go to school with my daddy
you know
so she's really appreciate that's what
made me happy
right right now i gotta be honest with
you i've been having an alright time
here
but watching her have a great time
makes my dick hard
what's the difference between when you
grew up there and now how what what are
the major changes holy [__] it's listen
i grew up in a city that was book
[__] wild no rules i was getting
dressed yesterday in the shower and i
was thinking about
a friend of mine getting me a job one
day and before he left the room he goes
enjoy your job you know and he goes
don't forget to steal because if you
don't steal
they're gonna know i was stealing who
the [__] tells you that in a society
so it was buck wild up there i live an
hour from where i grew up
where i grew up is really [__]
populated it's right across the hudson
river from new york city
so i didn't want to move up there there
was no way i was moving up there right
i'm in a place now where
you know it's wide open there's trees
the other was smoking a joint on my
front porch and two deer run ran in
front of me i thought i was gonna have a
[__] heart attack them dylan
i thought i was gonna [__] my [__]
pants when i seen those uh deer and my
front porch at a quarter to eleven
i got a cup of tea in me and i got half
a joint i'm just sitting and i heard
this [__] thing
and the two dear jumped out in front of
me and i almost [__] my pa it's a
different world tim yeah it's a
different world you know and uh
i'm happy i got to bring it here i'm
happy my wife is here she's having a
great time my wife had friends my wife
has friends now that don't give a [__]
who i am
right you know before she would make a
friend and after two weeks the girl
would say you know can we bring give
your husband a script
and my wife would go is this what it's
all about and then when my wife tells
him no they stopped talking to my wife
that was la for my wife yeah let's see
what they could get out of her on her
end
and uh if nothing move the [__] on you
know so right she's in a different place
now she's surrounded with real parents
yeah they care about their kids yeah
these people are not you know in l.a
people use their kids they're pimping
out their kids it's a [__] marketing
[__] tool
yeah no it's crazy
dope i know people who have a kid just
to put them in carpenter yeah they don't
give a [__] about the kid carpenter
school for people don't know it's in
studio city right and it's a grammar
school but it's where all the [__]
celebrities go their kids go to school
yeah and they have their christmas party
at cbs radford on the lot
yeah [__] public because i have a
godson who's like a quarter filipino but
we say chinese because we want them to
you know higher end
we say japanese or chinese we don't
admit to filipino but he's a but he's
the chubby
baby with the asian face i go let's get
him in some let's make a couple of
dollars here you know because the
reality is is you know he the only thing
he could be is is a nurse really because
his mother's in our filipino nurse i
said so let's just make let's get him
like he'll drink some juice he eats the
doughnut
let's make a few hundred grand of this
[__] before because he might
grow up to be a beautiful kid but he
also might grow up to be absolutely uh
disgusting we don't know
so i get it like in la like sometimes
you just gotta make the money while
they're young
let me tell you something i remember
going to [__] auditions
for commercials and seeing like you know
when you go to those auditions they have
eight rooms right and they have one room
that's for kids like kids come and
i would sit there and just watch the
parents
and watch the kids and [__] get sick
to my stomach yeah how the parents were
like because the parents are like pistol
pete's father yeah they're pushing the
kid they're telling the kid he's got to
get this audition the [__] poor kid
wants to play with blocks right you know
some of those kids are psychopaths you
know i well i was an actor as a kid when
i was young i was on sesame street i
started in plays when i was like six no
[__] swear to god and i legitimately i
did i toured around the country with a
show
my mother went on tour with me i did a
lot of theater i did a i did sesame
street i did a stu nyu student film i
never did anything big i tried out for
big [__] but i never got like home
improvement or any of those big sitcoms
i never got him um
and my parents were like they they
weren't good at being a stage mom like
they should have been pushier and more
aggressive but they weren't and then
every time i would fail at the audition
we would go home through penn station in
new york city and i would go can i go
can i go to dairy queen and they would
get me a dairy queen blizzard and i
would eat it like a failure in the
waiting room
uh of the long island railroad and i
would get i would get like i forget what
kind of get i get an oreo or reese's
peanut butter cup blizzard and i would
just sit there and eat it like a failure
and then we'd finally take the train
home
so it was a tragic thing but i i had fun
doing it but i never made it
but in minute 13 i became a cocaine
addict so maybe it's not good you
started snorting at 13. at 13 yeah holy
[__] some are going into high school
yeah jesus christ him dylan what haven't
you done i was at my friend tina
deluca's house and we're in long island
and she had a nice house on the water
and she goes we got you know me and a
couple other friends were there and you
know they were like let's try cocaine i
said that sounds like a great idea and
she had it and we did it didn't even
work
i didn't the first time i said uh it
doesn't even we had to keep doing it and
doing it and then finally uh you know it
took you got to drink with it yeah yeah
it took eventually but i mean i was
smoking wheat i was doing acid
uh you know all of those things yeah
first tab acid i was in um
my
first tab of acid you're gonna laugh
was at my friend's house
i was in eighth grade
the second time i did acid i was on the
graduation stage
of my junior high school and me and my
friend shay and my friend tina were like
a three
uh we all took ataba acid and we were
standing there and the valedictorian is
up there wouldn't shut up some you know
some asian girl and uh she was talking
and talking god bless her but she was
talking about
you know whatever you know and we were
just standing there and then finally we
went to the beach afterwards we were all
we were finally tripping but yeah i
started really young and then i sobered
up at 25 so i had about a 10 year
period of of being out and doing wild
[__] now you sober today sober's a
church no drinking no smoking no pills
no weed nothing
how long now
about 11 years no [__] tim
11 years yeah
the only thing i struggle with is
cigarettes i'm i'm not smoking them now
and i don't think i have smoked them for
a while because it co once you get
covered you start breathing you go
[__] you know i don't want to i
won't go back to cigarettes but like 11
years of nothing
that's tremendous
it's good yeah i'm i'm pumped about that
i'm happy about that it's funny when i
first started doing coke i was 16 the
first time i did coke
and
the first couple times i did it i wasn't
getting high i thought it was a joke
that's right yeah i thought it was a
joke on me i'm like you know how sad
night live people said it was [__]
hysterical i would run home to watch and
go this ain't funny yeah this ain't
[__] funny you know uh
samurai i mean i love belushi but that
[__] just wasn't funny to me at that age
so i thought it was part of the big joke
on uncle joey like it's a big [__]
joke nobody gets high on this [__]
and i would pay another 50 bucks for a
half gram try it again and nothing and
it was until one night
that we mugged steady freddie at putnam
fuel and we got an eight ball that i
started drinking michelob lights
and my jaw started going and i'm like
finally after [__] nine months yeah
i'm getting high on this [__] i threw my
i must have thrown two grand at this
[__] dealer
for nothing it was nothing but once i
started getting high it was tremendous
yeah we love it i love it
we used to do it in our office because
we were mortgage guys and it was good to
just we'd blast lines right off the desk
um how long did you stay up for how many
nights was your record i think my record
was close to three that's what was my
record three [__] three
think how sh how happy you are now yeah
that you're not
doing a three day as a [__] comic let
me tell you something as a comic
the worst thing you could have is a
monkey on your back that's true and go
on the road it's it's a horrible thing
and i told people
that if i still had the monkey on my
back i would have gone on the road every
weekend right that's what you do you're
on the road you snort coke
you [__] pick up freaks on the road
and you do what you do thank god
like i still remember getting [__]
high in beaumont
texas out of all with the weird places
eating 30 valiums
yeah the weekends 10 mil you know and
just so
the last
my last run on the road was sober you
know briefer and edibles
right you could i could still wake up at
seven and make radio it's not like you
get coked up and at 6 30. you got to
call the radio station
you're telling me not feeling good i'm
not feeling good i had some msg last
night
you got to call jim norton and tell him
at six in the morning i'm not gonna make
it i had msg because that's what usually
happened to me and it wasn't even
snorting coke it was just you get off
the plane
you're living in california hours
and you come to new york you're up to
four in the [__] morning right and
they want you in radio at 7 30 you're
like [__] i didn't fall asleep till 5
last night it must have been the msg
it was a general thousand chicken it was
a general tiles chicken and [__] yeah
i'm happy to not be doing it like to not
be doing it is is good
absolutely man it blocks you as a comic
yes comics think that you know i for
years tim dillon i did not quit snorting
coke
because i thought the funniness would go
out the [__] window
right i thought it made me wild
on stage and i thought it made me edgier
on stage you gave me like an edgy it's
like when somebody takes a picture with
a cigarette in their mouth right yeah
they're like
they're trying to look edgy or well they
take a picture with a budweiser in their
hand with somebody else with a budweiser
in their hands right
it's the same thing when you're doing
comedy i mean if you're a young comic
and you're snorting or doing pills i
tell you what and you're having a good
time i ain't mad at you
but if you really want your comedy to
soar
because i think the comedy blocks i
think the cocaine and the drugs blocked
your heart from your mind like
to put your heart really into your sets
i mean when i was doing coke i really
couldn't put my heart into a set that's
correct it wouldn't go through like the
my heart wouldn't go through it would
just be worse
you said it perfectly it blocks you and
in life in general that's what it does
right so
in life across the board it it blocks
who you truly are your true
capabilities your true potential from
being realized because you you know
you are a science experiment at that
point you know you are different you're
altered you're changed you're you're on
a drug you know oh and and you're
you're being impacted
by the substance so you're you're
you're you know it's you're you're an
experiment you don't know what you're
gonna do
and that's like when i used to hang out
with with people and
i would see them and they would be using
a lot of drugs i'd go
that person is becoming the drug they're
not even them anymore it's like they're
you know little by little whoever they
are is
is just becoming a you know you just
become like you're taken over by this
monster and you just exist to get the
drug your legs and arms are just to get
on phones and to drive cars to get the
drug it's crazy when you think about it
like that your
your operating systems hijack
and literally your entire day or
everything you think about everything
you do
it's all to just procure
this substance and do it and it's a
binary existence you're either high or
you're not you're happy or you're not
and i did that for a long time and it's
good to not be in that position now
14 [__] years for me i have no
regrets
right i couldn't snort a line of coke
now if you [__] paid me i don't care
if you
forced me to snort it off the girl's
[__] from [__]
hot chick that's like 50 years old that
used to date pete whatever his name is
davidson
i i don't care i don't i can't even
imagine
yeah what it would feel like now i have
a hard time with alcohol now right since
i moved here i drank a [__] claw one
day
i almost had a [__] heart attack
alcohol really doesn't agree with uncle
joey yeah
yeah you're at the point now it's
probably like you have your weed you
have an occasional stop at carvel that's
it you know you
we all pick our poisons and thank god
that
you know yours are manageable
i like that you're a carvel guy i see
you posting the fluffy the cakes yeah
yeah fudge to the well fudge whale yeah
there's nothing there's nothing better
it's the the best
ice cream in the united states i'll uh
you know i'll talk [__] to anybody that
denies that
it's [__] crazy that was i was
sitting with these parents yeah and they
said what are you gonna do after the
game and go this is about a month ago i
was going want to carve out and they go
what's that
oh and i go [__] you grew up in
newark you don't know where the [__]
carvel is and he's like nah we go to a
place called sundays listen that's done
yeah that's done we'll carve out people
i'm [__] team carvel [__] yeah
yeah tom carvel since 19 [__] 73.
yeah you know i've been running with
carvalho how are you going to break my
loyalty is [__] carvel
but i saw on your instagram you always
post them when you're on the east coast
that's my it's my favorite thing to do
when i get when i get on long island
that's it i mean it's like that was when
we you were growing up in long island if
you were good you got carvel you know
your parents would go
if you were good you could get carvel
that's how they would bribe us they'd go
we'll go to carvel just behave well go
to carvel on the way home just shut up
and you would have to behave for the day
and then you'll get carvel on the way
back and that was how they just kept us
alive i gotta tell you what tim dillon i
know you're a [__] professional i
don't mean to bring this up
i know you like your food
where i'm living in south jersey believe
it or not you know me i'm a [__]
loyal follower to carvel right but
there's a place on the nine
in freehold called jersey freeze
not [__] bad tim dillon
okay not [__] bad i went the last
time i was there as i was pulling in
bruce string springsteen was pulling out
really people were chasing with cameras
and [__] i'm like what the [__] just
happened
like you missed bruce springsteen i'm
like holy [__]
i saw him in the [__] jeep pulling
out
i thought it was him yeah i saw like
three little [__] homeless people
chasing them and [__] with cameras yeah
and then i went to eat the other night
and they're like you see that gym right
there bruce springsteen works out there
there's these [__] restaurants down
here from people from staten island that
have relocated
italians they got everything here tim
dylan bagels down here
you got wawa you got some tremendous
pretzels
i'll blast one of those in olive oil at
night when i'm stoned who the [__] eats
a pretzel with olive oil uncle joey
[__] so when you wake up in the
morning your [__] it comes out like a
[__] missile out of your [__]
no pushing no [__] gurgling
no nothing
you it's it's ten times the east coast
is just ten times better food than ellen
my god
it is so [__] good yeah it is
something careful yeah the chinese is
off i got a chinese place
80 yards from my door
she's always busy her name is lily yeah
she's [__] tremendous yeah every time
you go down there she gives you
something for free right like if you
order 20 bucks worth she throws in
[__] cream cheese wontons or right
yeah
it's a different [__] world tim dylan
how long have you been doing comedy for
now i started in this the fall of 2010
so the late late summer early fall late
august uh like i think august 25th might
have been my first set in 2010
so 11 years 11 years yeah
congratulations on all your success at
the 11 year mark
at the 11 year mark i was still getting
buried at the [__] comedy store yeah
well it was a quick 11 years it was an
intense 11 years um but it was also
looking at you guys you guys were the
blueprint you guys had the blueprint
right you and joe and skura and bert and
theo you guys had the blueprint of what
to do and you know do these shows and
entertain people on the internet and get
a fan base and then go out and entertain
them live it was like that blueprint was
something that helped me dramatically
and i
thank all of you guys and then all of
you guys being good to me and having me
on the shows it it sped up
that period of time it it it made me um
you know
it made me
um
aware of how difficult it was probably
to start these things when there was no
blueprint and you guys didn't know
what these things were going to be you
know rogan started in 2009
early there was a lot of people starting
this early when people were like you're
crazy you're crazy doing shows online
you should be doing television you
should be doing movies but a lot of you
guys
pioneering this stuff early
allowed people like me to go oh this is
the way to do it this is the root and
then my everything that's happened to me
i think was accelerated
because of you guys because i was able
to like follow in the footsteps of you
guys
i gotta be honest with you tim i just
watched mark maron yeah i watched joe
rogan i watched ralphie may
yeah
and i put that together
that was my you know i
looked up to rogan like i said in one of
the podcasts he was like my lighthouse
yeah like if i'd see him i knew where i
was at
right now
and i saw marc maron do a great job with
the podcast
and i just wanted to do something
different i always wanted to do radio
but i didn't want to do radio right that
style of ray it's joey diaz here in the
morning i didn't like that [__]
i wanted to rap you know like i wanted
to just talk to somebody on the radio
yeah like i wanted to do a little bit
better than talk radio when i first saw
artie lang
on howard stern that's what i wanted to
do yeah that was perfect for me
artie lang and stern were the [__]
blueprint there was one particular show
when hardy had their sunglasses on
and he's [__] up from the night before
and i'm like i want to go on there and
tell cocaine stories
the way artie's telling stories about
[__] heroin yeah that was it for me
that artie was the the lenny bruce
of the microphone you know in a studio
right he was very open with his life
copping hookers
heroin getting beat up by artie lang i
thank him
for letting me know what to do on a
podcast
yeah which was tell your stories and
tell the truth and don't hold nothing
back
right that's what makes for good
podcasting with rogan and those guys
its intelligence you know his his thing
was intelligence
i couldn't match his intelligence right
but i could [__] match
stories yes you know i grew up in jersey
i had a great childhood i had a horrible
childhood but i turned it into a great
childhood with my stories
yes
and that's what it was for me you know
basically just uh
do you miss los angeles at all ever is
there anything about it you miss
the insanity of it the craziness of it
that's what i miss sometimes i missed
the comfort that i made for myself right
i took studio city and i created my
little haven
i had cryotherapy i had my weed store
there i had my jiu jitsu there
i had my weight lift in there i pretty
much made those restaurants my life the
chinese place on ventura which is now
closed because of kovid
the wheat store ice cream shop
there were a couple pla you know my life
was too comfortable tim right
right i don't know if i could explain
that to you it was i had this little
world my office was two blocks from my
house you know all my friends lived in
the area lee
d'agostino dean del rey
we were bert kreicher we were all
condensed in there felicia
so i missed that
right i don't miss getting lied to
getting approached with [__] stories
right you know i don't miss any of that
[__] at all i do miss
there's a few people i miss there were
some good [__] people out there
but there was also some pieces of [__]
out there like worse than what i did
prison with
like people who come to you with a smile
they're worse than the cats i did time
with right right yeah you're not kidding
they're pieces of [__] compared to what
i did time with you know at least when
you do time
you know where you stand you know
you had a great line about people in l.a
once you said to me go you go
you go their minds aren't even their own
no which i thought was a brilliant way
to say it their minds aren't even their
own
great they sell their soul
yeah and then they sell their mind and
you start acting like that tim without
knowing
it's not their fault
they're on a tv show they're making 20
grand an episode they're [__] you
know this is the first time people come
up to them and talk to them
so they want to fit in you know so
they'll say whatever
to fit the [__]
even of of like uh
current issues
right like you know oh please save the
black people how many times have you had
black people in your house
cut the [__] [__] out right when i go
to your house and i see black people in
there in the [__] backyard well i'm
not talking about you know a black dude
that thinks he's white i'm talking about
leon and [__] booboo you know and the
cousins and the [__] dreadlocks when
i see them in your backyard then come to
me and talk about black lives matter
until that time you're just agreeing
with everybody else you see him at
[__] parades you know i care about
black people no you don't
no you don't no you don't give a [__]
about black people you know you want the
one michael jackson concert and that's
it
i went to see earth winning fire you
know i've been black since i came from
cuba you know what i'm saying like
these [__] will come to you oh
you got to stop with the black people on
the right no because you're not [__]
helping out right the biggest thing
about this pandemic to me was that you
had to get your house straight
that was the number one rule i was
taught get your house straight
how you act outside is how you gotta act
inside yeah but if you're gonna come
home you know what people say when
behind closed doors
that's what i want to hear from your
[__] mouth right i'll bug your house
and listen to those negroes in studio
city scared me you know we went down to
orange county we were surrounded by
philippines we smell pigeons that type
of [__] right that type of [__] that's
what i want to hear i don't want to hear
you say how you love me because you
really don't right you want to hear
honesty the truth you really don't and i
could tell when you're bullshitting i
could tell when you're [__] oh rest
in peace you were a kind soul no you
weren't you were a [__] scumbag you
stole me 25 bucks in that gigging veil
10 [__] years you know that's what
pissed me off that you lose your mind
not in a bad way people have a public
self and a private self yes
and and and i think
the more and more those two things
become further apart from each other
society gets really [__] up
people
people tend to they're only honest with
their friends
and then when they go outside they're
they're saying what they think they have
to say and then everything gets [__]
up because most people just go i don't
want any problems i don't want anything
and so
then whatever
is happening publicly
whatever we decide publicly is the truth
is just a few people deciding it and
then the vast majority of people keeping
their mouth shut because they don't want
to [__] they don't want any problems
and then they go into their house and
they go can you believe this this is
[__] i hate this [__] can you
imagine they're saying this is this
that's [__] but you catch them out
they go
and they don't ever say anything
so then you have a few people
and that decide how everything's going
to be for everybody
and that's what and i i feel it even
with myself and i talk so much [__] all
day all week everything but like there's
a lot of things where i go you know what
i don't want to even get into the
argument
like i don't want to get into the
argument i just want to live i don't
know how many years i have on this
planet why am i going to have the
argument it's a
it's a natural thing that happens to
people they just got i'm tired i'm tired
i don't want to get into the argument
you want to believe that believe it
you believe it might be insane it's
insane to me but you believe it so it's
a it's a weird place we're in right now
i don't i
the country
feels weird right now and i remember me
and you had to talk about this a few
months ago
it feels weird there's a there's
something that's not being said there's
a lot that's not being said but we're
not
where we were
uh clearly before this pandemic before
all this stuff a lot of people out there
have a lot of anxiety they don't know
what's happening
they don't know
the direction that things are going and
i feel like um
and it's not political it's none of that
[__] it's not like this one's right and
that one's wrong it's just i feel all of
us we have this ominous feeling
that
god forbid another shoe is gonna drop or
something else is gonna happen and and i
think it's uh you know it's scary
i mean nobody expected the afghanistan
thing right nobody saw that coming you
know uh
i'm not a political guy right but i know
that this week that's been the big
[__] issue you know when i speak to
people
i keep my mouth shut i listen i learn i
don't really know what's going on over
there
but one thing i will tell you that i
am proud of about
l.a the last 10 years i was in la i
didn't hold anything back
right you know when i shot movies or tv
shows one of the hardest things i had a
problem with was shooting tv shows and
movies i don't like the behavior of some
people how they act phony and [__]
when i went when i got off the powder
i went on a head hunting [__] ordeal
and then he sh
and he said i went to if i could tell
who the director is i don't want to be
on that set right like if i get on the
setting he's got a little hat with a
feather in it
and his sleeve is rolled up to show the
tattoo of the parrot right you go [__]
yourself you're not really a [__]
direct you know what i'm saying like it
was just
so i had a lot of problems i was told a
lot of times
i was tough to work with just because i
would speak my mind right you know and
uh i'm really proud of that because
from 97 to 2007 while i was doing coke i
wouldn't speak my mind
right because god forbid you break up my
little cocaine then
and my dreams you know i'd rather not
argue with you like uh there was a
situation i talk about with tommy at the
store
with him and another comment came up to
me and gave me [__] about joe
and i went home and didn't register that
they were picking a fight with me right
if i would have known what i know now i
would have put both of them through a
[__] wall but i didn't
and part of the reason was tim dillon my
cocaine habit right
right i didn't want to [__] up that
little world you know go to jail for two
days
three days because you smacked somebody
right once i got off the coke i i was i
remember i still remember the first time
i wanted a commercial shoot
and the director was being a dick to me
and i go i'm not taking this not tonight
it was a night shoot
right and i [__] went off on him and
he was so pissed he fired me and locked
himself in his trailer
and he wouldn't come out he kept saying
until you're gone i'm like it's three in
the morning you're not gonna hire
somebody else to shoot this right come
out be a man apologize
right let's shoot this and we'll wrap up
and go home and now you got you got the
saints in newark coming out
yeah no but that i had no problems on
that was a new york shoot
i see tim dillon there's a what i
learned was there's a big difference
between an la shoot
and a new york shoot right new york sets
are closed and they don't play that
agent [__] yeah where your agent shows
up and gets a free meal and i came to
check on you get the [__] out of here
you didn't come to check on me you came
to get the [__] free meal [__]
our agent will get three free meals a
day yeah yeah yeah so
so i don't i didn't want that
but shooting in new york i just shot
something for apple a few months ago
[__] painless yeah when i got the
rules they sent me rules tim dillon
right
i was like this ain't gonna work uncle
joey don't do good with rules
but once i got there with smooth and
that's what i
i'm really proud of that that i really
you know like i would call a comedy club
and i and justin would call me back and
go
uh they said that they can't book dean
del rey
because they already have a feature and
i would go well then tell them to give
me a week with there's no feature right
we'll simplify it why [__] around if
they already got a feature
let them stay and bring another headline
and then that was my way of saying
either you're in or you're [__] off
the boat right i'm bringing him i don't
give a [__] who you booked you should
have known better right so it was like i
didn't take [__] like i was like no
i'm not taking [__] and that freedom was
what got me to where i had to go
yeah once you break those soft lines
that new york shoot was i'm sure that
was a great experience doing that movie
it was one of the best experiences of my
life in the entertainment business yeah
because i learned something i learned
something from david chase
i learned how to get
comedy from quiet
he's the master
of getting comedy from a quiet room a
look
i tried to bring
our style of stand up on that set right
and the first day i realized it wasn't
going to work
right
that style of stand-up was not he was
doing something completely different and
when i saw what he was doing it blew my
wig off so much
that i had to join in i had to join
scientology
right
like i became
one of his [__] guys like i'm like i
understand what he's trying to do
i never worked for somebody that had a
plan like that i've worked with some
great people
some great directors but he was
brilliant tim yeah you're right about
that when you watch the sopranos you see
a lot of the funniest moments or looks
reactions things like that he really
taught me about looks reactions and
quiet how you have to say a joke and
shut the [__] up right let it ruminate
in the room let it go you know like when
you did theaters at first
people say to you theaters are different
you know you have to say the joke and
shut up and let it ruminate the room is
big
it's a [__] theater just machine gun
them to death
but it's that's what i learned in new
york at 56 years old
so when i learn something
i'm in
i'm one of those guys if you got
something to teach me
i'm [__] in
right
that's important it's important that you
keep
challenging yourself to be better
because otherwise you get bored you get
bored you know that's what happened with
me with stand up right now i'm a little
bored
i'll give it a breather i'll let all
this [__] pass passes
yeah and when i'm ready i go on there
with a base you know like you want to do
it
there's nothing worse than doing comedy
and not want to do it
that's there's nothing worse than
showing up dangling i didn't want to
[__] work tonight right you know and
i had a lot of those the last couple of
years so i figured i'd give it a little
breather
let tim dillon take over the [__]
world
well we'll stream
in trying to
try to do the best that i can and uh you
guess i got sidelined with this thing
for a minute but i'll be back up it's
like
it's shitty there's so much out there
you don't control
you know and i'm on on a roll i'm on a
roll and doing shows and shows and shows
and then you get hit with this and you
go you [__] health and then you're
like [__]
this is what you don't have any control
over
well tim dillon i feel in my heart that
this is just a bump in the road for you
yes
you have a great [__] plan you're one
of those comics that's very intelligent
that sees things for what they were
for what they are not what they were
thank you you know just what you told me
about the spring that everything should
be you know you you've always been very
knowledgeable
and i'm right here clapping for you
waiting to take over the world my friend
well let's hope we'll see i mean i don't
know if i want the world i don't want to
take over the world i want to make a few
people laugh and make some money but
everybody else can have the world
the world is is a little bit of a mess
that that uh taylor tomlinson can have
the world she'll do a better job
just give me a little cord just give me
some carvel
that's all you know i got to tell this
tim dillon story real quick i was
watching one of your videos everybody
was telling me about tim dillon i'm
watching one of your videos two three
years ago i'm laughing and i see you a
week later at the start i'm like what
the [__] is this guy gonna say and you
came up you're the sweetest man in the
world you were like hey weight watchers
work and i'm like
that's how we started talking i'm like
out of all the things tim dylan could
have said to me he's like wait wait
watch is working for you i go yeah you
know i like it i've been on it wow
[__] 18 years i finally lost some
weight and [__] i love it yeah yeah have
you done it during the pandemic and not
really yeah yeah i stuck to my points
during the surgery oh wow when i had
knee surgery knee replacement i couldn't
do anything i had no metabolism so
yeah i started the [__] points you
know and i eat i just don't [__] with
sugar right i'll eat sugar maybe once a
week like a snack with my daughter when
we go to carvalhos and i'll get an ice
cream soda without ice cream in it right
i'm one of those [__] jerk-offs you
know so
what's that ice cream soda without ice
cream what do you mean by that
they when she gives me the ice cream
soda with the ice cream in it i take it
out and i give it to my daughter and she
puts in her chocolate ice cream soda oh
okay yeah she likes the ice cream and
her soda so i give it to her and i just
drink the [__] thing and it's like
20 points but it's really club soda with
vanilla syrup so right right right
you're not going to [__] die you know
what i'm saying what's the name of your
tour tim dillon
uh the tour i think we're going to call
it the post post-apocalyptic tour i like
it when does it kick off
well it was it was happening and then we
got we got kicked back in with cove and
it should kick back off soon we're
hoping we're seeing we're seeing
uh when we can get back out there
well i love you tim dillon i love see
you thank you i saw you posted uh
uh dates for the beacon theater yes
beacon in new york city
november i'm pumped about that okay i'm
gonna come see you and say hello and
give you some [__] love if the
numbers don't ruin it for you yeah and
the [__] face mask and the
vaccinations and all the [__]
but i love you keep in touch thank you
brother tell ben i love that [__]
yes i will ben's a good man and uh we'll
do what we did we had lee we had lee
come in tremendously
one of the funniest things i've ever
done i think what was the look on ben's
face i saw it but my glasses didn't let
me see the full effect look on his
[__] face it's so funny when we had
lee come in there we saw liam boston
he's got a girl he's doing great yeah
thank you joey thank you so much and i'm
excited to see you in the movies love
you brother stay black and i'll be in
touch thank you for being on the joint
thank you buddy thank you
boom
i hope you enjoyed tim dillon it was
always a pleasure talking to him he made
me laugh
uh like i said he's the future of
[__] comedy
and he was on the joint today to help us
out to make the week go a little
smoother and make your day
be [__] nice that's what we do here
i'm not trying to set the world on fire
i'm just trying to come through on
mondays and wednesdays
give you a [__] giggle
learn you learn something and we move
the [__] on i'm not looking to be
[__] johnny
bananas of the podcast world
i'm old i got [__] on my plate and i
just want to get to you [__]
twice a week and let you know i love you
i'm still doing my thing
and i'm still here i hope you enjoyed
tim dillon it was a great interview it
was great to see him i'm happy he's
getting healthy i'm happy he's going
back to l.a and he's going to light the
[__] world on fire we're getting old
so we got to make room for these [__]
youngsters that's just the way it is you
can't take this [__] personally you know
what i'm saying it's your attitude
[__] but anyway we had a great
week
monday we had a great week today we had
a great show i hope you guys enjoyed it
and i'll be back next week monday
morning nice and early
tip top magoo
ready to tell you a story ready to give
you an ear beaten then we'll be back on
wednesday with another fun-filled
podcast i love you guys
have a great week and uh
the summer's coming to an end stay black
now for a word for my [__]
sponsor jack
all right i want to thank tim dillon
for coming on i love that [__]
he's a nut
and i want to thank you guys for
supporting us this week
my patreon family i love you guys you
know we're trying over there
thank you very much for all the support
you've given me you can see i'm making a
comeback little by little my mind's
getting right
uh some of it is therapy some of it is
working out some of it is [__]
alpha brain but most of it is my balls
in my heart but anyway the joint is
brought to you by zip recruiter you want
a job every place is hiring right now
zip recruiter has a fancy technology
that finds the best people for the job
and it helps you get them it tells you
who's most qualified and invites them to
apply
it works you're going to get two and a
half more candidates this way and anyway
you put it four out of five employers
who post on zip recruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day
forbes magazine says gyms salons
hotels are going to go on a hiring spree
in the next few months
millions of jobs will be need to be
filled as businesses keep reopening how
do you hire people fast uncle joey's got
the answer zip recruiter try it for free
at ziprecruiter.com
joey you got nothing
to lose here's the difference with zip
recruiter you're just not posting a job
and waiting for a resume from joe schmo
to come in
zip recruiter has fancy technology that
finds the best people
for the job and helps you get them it
tells you who's most qualified and
invites them to apply and it works get
two and a half times more candidates
this way right now go to ziprecruiter
for free
joey what are you talking about four out
of five employees who post on
ziprecruiter get a quality candidate
within the first day and i'm giving it
to you for free
that's right that's ziprecruiter.com
joey j-o-e-y try it for free just by
going to ziprecruiter.com
joey zip recruiter the smartest way to
hire the joint is also brought to you by
my all-time favorite
me undies you want your nuts to be
comfortable you shaved them you put
cologne on them from manscape you got
them all buffed and now you got them in
a white pair [__] whitey connie
whatever the hell you call those things
tidy whities you don't need those things
don't think don't do nothing to help
your nut sack or keep anything dry or in
place that's where me undies comes in
let me tell you something me undies are
designed to be the softest thing on
earth
that may sound like a [__] [__]
story but it's the truth softer than a
baby's butt softer than a feather
me and tim were talking about a carvel
cake that's right it's softer than a car
though [__] cake how me undies
signature micro modal fabric literally
grows on trees
that means these undies are soft and
sustainable that's what you want
when somebody's cupping your little nut
sack they offer different cuts because
they're that cool they get you different
cuts for different butts that's their
model
plus check out their socks bralettes for
your girlfriend loungewear and of course
all the undies ranging from extra small
to 4xl for your little chubby people
me undies has a great offer for the
joint listeners
for any first timers get 15
off your first order this is a deal in
itself and
free shipping at meundies.com
joey again that's meundies.com
joey the best underwears in the business
i'm gonna take a picture of my [__]
draw and put it on instagram to show you
how many [__] me undies i have and
how well they're used and how they look
there's no bulges you know yeah a little
white underwear has got holes in them
and [__] from you farting in there
nothing like that with me undies the
material is tremendous that moldova it's
comfortable and it's tough and it's
sustainable
so check out me on these problem-free
philosophy if you're not satisfied with
any product for any reason they'll
refund or exchange it no questions asked
that's meundies.com
joey meundies.com
comfort where it counts
the joint is also brought to you by c
b
d
lion the leader in [__] cbd i don't
know about martians i don't know about a
lot of [__]
but i know weed related stuff and cbd
line has helped me
with my surgery with the cbd line extra
strength cream
to the roll on from my [__] knees and
elbows and shoulders to the hem the
flower if you want to smoke it they got
vapor pens they got little capsules they
got
tremendous gummies the mixed fruit
vegan cbd gummies with melatonin oh my
[__] god they will put you asleep
like a baby and the bat ball i mean just
go to cbdlion.com look at the third
party lab results and read
learn about cbd cbn cby
and how
cbd lion is the leader he's the king of
the jungle
so go to cbdline.com right now and press
in joey or church and get 20 off
delivered to your house i want to thank
zip recruit i want to thank
meundies cbd lion
draftkings for coming in strong this
week with the nfl
better dollar on any game one week and
you're going to win 200 bucks and
credits you know uncle joey's here for
you on it coming through
all he is i love you bowling branch
coming through
i love my sponsors i love you guys too
have a great week i'm happy you enjoyed
tim dillon stay black and we'll be back
monday morning ready to [__] rock
tip top magoo
have a great week [__]
come see me on patreon and laughing gas
is back in stock at the ice cream shop
stay black
[Music]
you